every esport has its goat whether it's a
particular player or a roster that
builds a dynasty being the best of the
best guarantees you a special place in
the history books SK telecom have
overcome every challenge they are the
Undisputed best team in the world the
SKT ring continues they win their third
world championship
of course some events are more
prestigious than others and offer
winners highly coveted trophies and
massive prize pools still most players
compete because they want to be able to
say that they're number one at what they
do even if it's one of csgo's dumbest
game modes
oh no the string of me I feel like I've
done some really risky oh okay that I
did not mean that to happen
I genuinely didn't mean that episode
right here right here going
come out
meet Chad sponge burchill and his
wingman for Life Alexander rushly Rush
the unlikely Duo who mastered csgo's
famously terrible Battle Royale game
mode and made it their mission to
humiliate each and every opponent they
encountered on their way to the top so
how did one of counter-strike's most
beloved casters join forces with an
observer to become the deadliest duo in
the game's most insignificant game mode
how did they help shape the danger zone
meta and how on Earth did they recover
from this
this is worse than Summit Rush this is
just that is
what a blunder
okay so before we get into it I just
want to remind you all that we have
merch head over to shop.thescore.com and
check out our Esports collection where
we have tons of cool hoodies and
t-shirts in different styles and
colorways all right so if you are a fan
of Counter-Strike then there is a very
good chance that you know who sponges he
has commentated some of Cs Go's biggest
events for nearly a decade now and even
if you don't know what he looks like
you've definitely heard his voice oh
it's felt like we've been on a highlight
draft it's a roller coaster now this is
just Madness spray Downs clutches flanks
are in the back lines
this game has changed forever that
wasn't the most telegraphed execute that
you've ever seen in your entire life
last phase I think they'll tell you what
it was
bomb goes off and axile the smooth he is
so swish isn't he jumps off the building
I've been talking about that yes dude
he's got the timing down alongside his
partner in crime machine sponge has
casted some of csgo's greatest matches
this is huge info play from electronic
here we haven't seen him operate this up
close and personal sure he's like the
aggression but he's been found out
before and twists talk about his impact
this would be some time to find out the
rat in the hole
the dying stages of Regulation as
they're gone 15.
[Applause]
to sit down but long before his days as
a caster and analyst sponge was one of
the most beloved Aussie Counter-Strike
players competing in source for Sydney
underground in the championship gaming
series back in 2008. after CS go
launched in 2012 sponge continued to
make a name for himself with Vox eminor
leading the roster to three Majors
before getting picked up by Renegades in
June of 2015 but when things went South
the blame was often directed at the
team's Captain sponge despite this he
never shied away from speaking about the
harassment that Renegades faced I
definitely don't think we make excuses
for ourselves and we understand when we
play bad you know we're the ones who get
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
people messaging us on Twitter like like
death threats and saying like [__] you
for losing all my skins and [__] like
we're the ones who sit there and we we
cop all of that and I understand that
casters and everything they have to
critique the players that's their job I
get it unfortunately in 2016 things went
from bad to worse for sponge simply to
apply pressure for Yam it'll cover off
one set object one set angle but
skadoodle's holding it down he goes
repeat from skadoodle and he's gonna hit
him both say what you want about Cloud9
and nacs but it's four teams now from
the US in the major one more than any
other Majors ever provided Renegades
narrowly missed out on the Columbus
major and that loss to Cloud Nine marked
the beginning of the end of sponge's
playing days earlier that month he
commented on a Reddit thread stating
that he stopped tweeting as much as he
normally would and that he had pretty
much given up on streaming he also said
that he couldn't take all of the abuse
that the community was throwing at him
and after getting criticized for his
poor performance at the Columbus major
qualifier sponge deactivated his Twitter
only to return a few months later
announcing his retirement from Pro play
luckily he managed to land on his feet
he began doing analysts work for ESL
throughout the remainder of 2016 which
allowed him to continue sharing his
boisterous personality with
Counter-Strike fans over the coming
years I got one thing to say Alex I only
have one thing to say
what is coming next what's coming next
this is outrageous absolutely incredible
scenes
Chad's off to celebrate with them I
guess we'll have to operate with a
three-man desk now as sponge entered
this new chapter of his career someone
else joined the team over at ESL and
while you may not recognize him just by
looking at him I can almost guarantee
that you will recognize his voice hey
future Pros hey future Pros hey future
Pros hey future Pros hey future Pros
that's you guys you get listen to this
chat this is you guys future pros this
pipe vent and slightly to the right of
the Line run forward and jumping through
the smoke as you get close to the wall
in front that's you guys do that
Alexander Rush also known as rushly is a
British Observer for ESL he and sponge
obviously work for the same company but
when exactly did their stories
intertwine well back in 2018 the gaming
world was being dominated by battle
royale's like fortnite and Val wanted to
capitalize on the hype so they released
their own Battle Royale mode for
Counter-Strike called danger zone now
similar to other battle Royals you drop
onto the map search for Loot and kill
your enemies all while staying inside
the shrinking safe area now suffice it
to say most CS players
didn't really give a [__] about
dangerous like sure we all gave it a
shot for two weeks but most people
recognize that to be valves half-hearted
attempt to jump onto the Battle Royale
bandwagon
instead of giving us a real [__]
anti-cheap and those people did have a
point because the game mode kinda sucked
players experienced tons of performance
issues and it didn't take long for the
player base to die out but a few months
after its release ESL inexplicably
decided to host a danger zone show match
at katowicea 2019 and the rest is
history and we've also got Pimp's
partner now I don't know if you guys
recognize this gentleman he's a bit of a
legend backstage because he's one of our
observers here it's rushly what's it
like to be front of the stage freshly
it's a bit different I'm not used to it
but I'm here to play I'm here to win
that's the key thing I'm not messing
around today it's my time to shine this
is it unfortunately once the matches got
underway rushly and pimp didn't do so
hard yeah you need the cash monies for
that oh good battle for gratisfaction
he's got three kills in this game
again Eddie put on the back foot
satisfaction is having a game and a half
rushly and pimp got smoked in game one
and across the stage sponge and his
teammates weren't doing so hot either in
fact they were the first team to go down
in game one and two but rushley's
performance in game two was somehow
worse
like
much worse
Rush uh well he's in the yeah he's
taking damage he's outside of the safety
zone
I wonder if this wall could really ruin
his life really it's he's not having fun
with it
a shake of the heads he was so confident
at the start he's just straight gonna
die this is worse than Summit Rush this
is just that is
what a blunder
rushly did manage to get a kill in the
third and final game but it was too
little too late I don't bottom it's pimp
and rush I probably could have predicted
that they would join but I'm gonna give
them bottom purely off Russia's
destination Now look for most people
finishing dead last on land at a
katavita would be pretty demoralizing
but for rushly this was merely the
beginning of his revenge tour from that
day on he was an observer by day and a
killing machine by night he and sponge
joined forces and took some bump mine
inspiration from a streamer named Sid to
become the most deadly Duo the game mode
had ever seen
are you jumping yep I want him
oh
[Music]
like danger clothes like I'm probably
dead like
like
oh they're fighting I'm gone
[Music]
and there it is sponge and Rush became
danger zone gods and as time went on
they began getting more and more
creative with their frags the two of
them were so cracked that ESL even let
rushly make an entire episode of pro
tips dedicated solely to Danger Zone hey
future Pros today I'm traveling to the
wonderful world of Sirocco to teach you
all how to use the mobility package to
its fullest potential in danger zone yes
danger zone is still a thing and yes
people still play it look honestly
rushley's Rise To Danger Zone stardom is
nothing short of remarkable the dude
went from dying in basically the dumbest
way imaginable on one of
counter-strike's biggest stages to
mastering a game mode that no one plays
and sharing Advanced Techniques with the
community and as for sponge it gave one
of the most respect Minds in
Counter-Strike the ability to flex on
Scrubs once again
even if it is in CS goes
stupidest game mode and now the two of
them truly sit in A League of Their Own
as danger zone royalty
twice
with CS2 on the way it's obviously not a
guarantee the danger zone will make a
return in the newest installment of
valve's iconic franchise but with
in-game taunts allegedly on their way
some people suspect the danger zone will
be a part of Counter-Strike too and if
it is then I think there's a reasonable
chance that we will continue to see
Sponge and rushly build upon their
legacy as the goats of counter-strike's
most ridiculous game mode
I talk [__] I got hit
of course now he's in danger Penny
recover from Virgil's massive blunder
there's no ammo left the knife
[Music]
is he gonna make this work Circle spawns
in
I am a battle royale elitist I only play
the best hardest Battle Royale I only
play danger zone like any true
Counter-Strike elitist I refuse to even
Dane to to touch on any of these titles
like fortnite or [__] Cod or Apex or
whatever
[Music]